In 2011, Zack Snyder's stylish, violent Sucker
Punch hit theaters and introduced audiences
to a cast of butt-stomping young ladies in
leather.
With a steampunk sensibility, a complex fantasy-inside-a-dream
narrative, and memorable performances from
a cast of up-and-comers, it was one of the
most unique films of the year — even if
critics kinda hated it.
But what happened to Babydoll and all her
friends after the cameras stopped rolling?
Here's where they all ended up.
Emily Browning
Some folks thought that Sucker Punch would
catapult Emily Browning to A-list superstar
status, but her career trajectory was still
just as oddball and eclectic as ever.
Turns out, a typical Hollywood trajectory
is the last thing on her mind.
She's been very picky about when and where
she shows up onscreen since Sucker Punch;
her most mainstream role in the past five
years was in the historical disaster flick
Pompeii, but her bread and butter is the foreign
and festival circuit, where she turns up in
movies that most mainstream audiences will
never even hear about, let alone see in theaters.
As of 2017, you're most likely to catch her
on the small screen, where she's scored a
prime role in the Starz adaptation of Neil
Gaiman's American Gods.
She's also kept a low profile in real life
— dating a guy much less famous than she
is and running an eclectic Instagram account
that is as un-Hollywood as they come.
Vanessa Hudgens
Sucker Punch was a big move away from Vanessa
Hudgens' Disney roots, and she kept moving
in the same direction with follow-up roles
in Spring Breakers and Gimme Shelter.
However, Hudgens clearly hasn't gotten the
musical theater geek entirely out of her system;
a few years after her gun-slinging, grenade-throwing
turn as Blondie, she was back to belting ballads
as Betty Rizzo on Grease Live!
More recently, she's enjoy ing a starring
role on primetime TV comedy Powerless, where
she plays an employee at Wayne Security, developing
products to keep people safe during destructive
superhero battles.
She also keeps up with fans on Instagram,
because of course she does.
Abbie Cornish
You've gotta love Abbie Cornish's capacity
for reinvention.
Before Sucker Punch, she was known primarily
as the leading lady of the period romance
Bright Star.
But just as Cornish refused to be pigeonholed
into a corseted career after that, she also
kept it interesting and unusual after her
leather-clad turn in Sucker Punch.
She's starring in Geostorm, an action flick
with Gerard Butler, working with mega-stars
Woody Harrelson and Frances McDormand on a
dark comedy, and speaking out in an eloquent
defense of the controversial film Where Hands
Touch.
And that's not all: Cornish is also known
to occasionally take a break from her acting
life to spit rhymes in her second career as
a rapper.
Yeah, really.
"Gotta spin this, hoping that I win this.
Shameless, blameless soul, up in this, just
got the stars as a witness.
Hit this, like I'm gonna miss this, wishin'."
Jena Malone
By the time she scored a role in Sucker Punch,
Jena Malone had been acting for ages, and
she didn't slow down afterward.
In 2012, she traded her leather bustier for
a long skirt and high-necked blouse on the
period TV drama Hatfields & McCoys; the following
year, she joined the cast of The Hunger Games:
Catching Fire as Johanna Mason.
Malone re-teamed with Sucker Punch director
Zack Snyder in 2016 for Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice, but her scenes as Jenet Klyburn
were deleted from the theatrical release.
Lately, though, Malone is less involved in
Hollywood and more interested in her new roles
as a mom, a photographer, and a writer.
The actress gave birth to her first child
with fiance Ethan Delorenzo in May 2016, and
she now shares thoughts, poetry, and photos
on a blog called Our Mountain Family.
That's a long way from gunning down bad guys.
Jamie Chung
Scoring a role in Sucker Punch was a major
coup for Jamie Chung, who got her start on
MTV's The Real World and used the show as
a launchpad into a legit acting career.
Since 2011, you're most likely to have seen
her in repeat appearances on Once Upon a Time,
where she plays the role of Mulan — or heard
her in the role of GoGo in Big Hero 6, which
she'll be reprising for the TV series, too.
And Chung hasn't left the action realm behind;
she's been cast as the teleporting mutant
Blink in Fox's new X-Men series.
Carla Gugino
After playing a therapist-slash-dance-madam
in Sucker Punch, Carla Gugino hasn't lost
her taste for the dark and weird.
Since then, she's held down major roles on
Wayward Pines and Californication — and
she's even teamed up with director Zack Snyder
for a third and fourth time, lending her voice
to a Kryptonian robot, and then a Kryptonian
spaceship, in his Superman films.
As of 2017, she's starring in the sci-fi spectacle
The Space Between Us and a feature film adaptation
of the Stephen King novel Gerald's Game.
Oscar Isaac
Between Ex Machina, X-Men: Apocalypse, and
Star Wars: The Force Awakens, you can't go
to the movies these days without seeing Oscar
Isaac in some form or another — which makes
him the one member of Snyder's Sucker Punch
cast who's exponentially more famous now than
he was in 2011.
Isaac was right at the start of his career
when he scored a minor role in Sucker Punch.
Now, he's one of the hottest actors in Hollywood,
with half a dozen prestigious projects coming
down the pike.
But perhaps because he got so mega-famous
so fast, Isaac keeps a comparatively low profile
in real life.
He's so secretive about his private life that
there's practically an entire cottage industry
dedicated to unraveling the mysteries of how
he spends his time when he's not onscreen.
Jon Hamm
Though he kept busy with Mad Men for most
of the early 2000s, Jon Hamm was never so
busy that he couldn't take a moment between
seasons to show up in a movie or two — and
in Sucker Punch, he played a small but pivotal
role.
In one narrative, he's the brothel's smarmy
VIP client; in the other, he's the asylum
doctor who lobotomizes helpless young ladies
with a stainless steel awl.
Needless to say, Jon Hamm didn't disappear
after Sucker Punch; he continued for another
several years on Mad Men, winning a Golden
Globe and an Emmy for his performance as Don
Draper.
Not that it's all been sunshine and daisies
for Hamm in the intervening years — his
longtime relationship with Jennifer Westfeldt
ended in 2015, just a few months after Hamm
announced that he'd entered rehab for alcohol
addiction — but he's still as sought-after
as ever.
Next up, look for him in Edgar Wright's hotly-anticipated
heist flick Baby Driver.
Scott Glenn
There's just something about Scott Glenn that
says "grizzled badass" — which is why, after
appearing as Babydoll's pseudo-spirit guide
in Sucker Punch, he's since gone on to play
virtually the same role in the Netflix series
Daredevil, only minus his eyesight and plus
a very big stick.
Glenn is as tough off-screen as the characters
he plays.
The dude is approaching 80 and still trains
with Seal Team 6 to stay in shape for his
roles.
And when he's not making a movie or TV show,
he's a die-hard thrill-seeker.
If he's not on camera, you'll probably find
him riding motorcycles, jumping out of planes,
or spear-fishing in the middle of the open
ocean.
When you're beating up fish with your bare
hands, you know you've made it.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!